c'est un terrible drame qui s'est
déroulé il ya 15 jours à marseille
une adolescente de 15 ans est
électrocuté dans son bain à cause de son
téléphone portable alors que la jeune
fille utiliser son smartphone en prenant
son bain l'appareil qui était en train
de charger et qui par conséquent et est
toujours branché au secteur a glissé
dans l'eau et a provoqué l'électrocution
de l'adolescente prise en charge par les
secours elle a été déplacée vers
l'hôpital de la timone
mais malgré les efforts du centre de
réanimation elle n'a pas survécu
un tragique fait divers qui n'est pas
une exception en décembre dernier c'est
un enfant de 9 ans qui perdaient la vie
dans les mêmes conditions chaque année
40 personnes meurent par électrocution
en france et ce n'est pas le seul danger
des téléphones portables car 72 % des
enfants utilisent au moins un appareil
connecté dans leur environnement de
sommeil et sans dormir avec son
téléphone branché dans le lit peut
s'avérer catastrophique en raison de
défauts de fabrication ou de mauvais
contact des chargeurs de nombreux
incendies sont chaque année déclenché à
cause des téléphones portables bref un
danger omniprésent dont beaucoup de
parents ne prennent pas la mesure
alors le père de typhaine serge qu'on
comprend et voilà il a poussé un coup de
gueule parce que cette victoire c'est
incroyable il regarder la vidéo du père
de typhaine la dernière victime
s'appelle typhaine elle avait 15 ans son
père l'a retrouvé dans son bain dans les
mêmes circonstances dimanche dernier il
pousse un cri de colère fait des
téléphones ou des chargeurs qui qu'ils
soient capables de john t quand ils sont
en contact avec l'eau je pense qu'on
évitera beaucoup de choses on pense très
fort à ach bien entendu qu a vécu ce
drame
voilà on lui envoie de la force parce
que c'est vrai que ça doit être terrible
pour lui merci et en belgique mais c'est
incroyable alors je vous donnais les
trois on a voulu recenser les trois
conseils les plus importants pour ceux
qui ont des tales voilà qui les mettent
partout qui sont dans le bain avec tout
ça surtout avoir le bon câble de
recharge
je vous dis il ya des câbles voilà quand
vous voyez que câble et un petit peu ça
voilà ça c'est pas possible parce que ça
ça provoque des incendies des
surchauffes et vous voyez appelé eu
plein d'un incendie dans la nuit à cause
de câbles comme ça donc fait très très
attention à ça de ne pas recharger son
téléphone dans son lit je vous le dis ne
le laissez pas dans votre ligne
ça c'est extrêmement dangereux aussi je
vous le dis son téléphone dans son lit
puisque tout le monde le fait
après free en avec voilà et les
batteries sont pas toutes constituée de
composants stable elles peuvent être
très sensibles aux fortes températures
et le fait de déplacer un téléphone ou
une tablette en charge sous une
couverture ou un oreiller peut suffire à
provoquer l'échauffement de la batterie
ou même de son chargeur donc voilà je
vous le dis il faut éviter aussi de
mettre dans des conditions extrêmes ou
très froid ou très chaud et ne pas
recharger son téléphone dans une pièce
humide
malheureusement il ya plus en plus de
décès par électrocution
j'vous l'dit ni à l'utilisation de
téléphones portables dans la salle de
bain le victimes meurent des suites d'un
choc électrique est généralement elle
était jeune et en bonne santé
forcément chaque année je vous dis c'est
énorme le chiffre on recense 40 décès
par électrocution en france et environ
3000 par électrisation donc c'est vrai
qu'on en parle peu mais ça c'est ça la
ccin fléau un joli voilà dans la salle
de bain voilà qui kills qui le fait ça
oui moi je le fais malheureusement je
prenais devenu un peu exclame de nos
portables
mais c'est aussi à cause des marques ldc
waterproof allez-y vous pouvez
l'utiliser n'importe où moi je t'ai lice
heureusement mais je le ferai plus mon
portable pour regarder par me le répéter
pmb sous ma douche à madame est douce
mais c'est extrêmement dangereux et je
me rends compte que je suis devenu
esclave de mon bord alors info il faut
que le téléphone soit bon voilà c'est
sur les charges tous à l'arrivée d'un
jeu mais ses biographes à la wifi
téléphones on peut ajouter l'ordinateur
il ya beaucoup de gens qui s'endorment
en regardant leur ordinateur un film où
les mails les acteurs puis qui le laisse
après en charge mais c'est pareil que le
téléphone sauf que ça peut être plus
gros il ya de graves dangers d'incendié
ne jamais avoir un ordinateur branché
garder dans son lit comme un téléphone
j'ai rien oui et un jour et on va quand
même révélé qu'il ya des ondes
extrêmement nocives qui sont dégagées
par un téléphone même éteint faut
surtout pas les garder à côté de son lit
et le relier au moins pu faire beau par
ailleurs il faut dire aussi aux
téléspectateurs que peu importe la
charge que vous avez c'est à dire votre
prise même si c'est une prise qui est
une prise de la marque à la pomme
vous vous dites bon bah ça c'est pas un
truc que j'ai acheté sur un site un peu
un peu machin peu importe dans tous les
cas de figure c'est électrocution donc
c'est pas parce que vous avez un truc et
réglementaire entre guillemets que vous
serez pas renié voilà